Salima Tech is practicing how to
seamlessly weld a pipe he's hard at work
nearly every day he came to Germany from
Algeria two years ago but is still
waiting for a decision on his asylum
application and doesn't know if he can
stay
despite this he's learning to be a
heating engineer at a training center in
Duisburg I like this work I hope I can
find a job you know this dream could
become a reality in just two years
that's when Salah Manteca and sixteen
other refugees are expected to receive
their diplomas for plumbing and heating
installation there are currently
thousands of unfilled positions in this
profession in Germany working is really
good for me I just want to work work
work business leaders have long been
calling for more asylum seekers in the
job market
but refugees have a tough time with
applications because they almost never
have proof of their qualifications think
about the people fleeing across the
Mediterranean and tragedies like lapa
doce the thing they don't bring with
them is certificates everything in their
head but nothing to prove it most people
here have a good foundation in a trade
it's just not certified but that's no
problem don't get that here job my from
Syria has also just started training as
a heating engineer but he's doing so
with a German company rather than the
training center he was studying
veterinary science back home before he
fled now he's struggling with the
terminology in this new line of work
sometimes they ask me for one thing and
I get something completely different
it's hard I didn't do much manual labour
in Syria I was a student and now I'm
always working with my hands plus
there's the language
this means G odd mine needs even more
help with his reports than the other
trainees but his boss is sure he'll
catch up at least G odd has been granted
the right to stay in Germany had that
not been the case his boss probably
wouldn't have offered him an
apprenticeship great potential in
refugees there are many young
enthusiastic and well educated people
among them and I think this potential
has not been fully exploited it's one
thing for business to consider taking on
refugees but to take the leap and say
okay I'll actually employ someone some
businesses still have reservations like
the Dinkin but and I don't even jog my
has only just started but he's already
planned what he'll do after his
apprenticeship he wants to earn a
master's certification so that he can
train others the students back at the
training centre can't plan that far
ahead
their asylum applications haven't yet
been finalized so their right to stay
hangs in the balance at the end of this
year they'll do their first internship
at a company where they can secure
contracts for future employment they're
knuckling down studying German in
preparation if you live or work in
Germany you have to be able to
understand the language I think that's
really important
then it's off to the canteen for a break
for our solemn attack and his friends
Cola and fries at least this parts easy
to get used to